there are opposite sides the point right
now there's nowhere for because oh nice
dodge on the hook
Mickey cleans up to kill on to bunny
that's right but not going to hit carpet
crumbs on the side though Oh get some
style weather highlight reel baking
right here ladies and gentlemen Reza
full scope and time ooh her is wonderful
of a twiddle baker so far tonight work
oh what a shot for my moon yeah sorry
Tommy target back mailers we ran very
very heavily by this back lawn garden
here's the castle they don't think we
find speak of the headstone stick nd
trying to get over the wall is becomes
big one your your time you want to walk
three in four plates again again number
one eat chili paste big man why does I
don't bring Ria's to stroll right on
through okay in where you are Saudis
head sliced off the male partner with
the rest of ambience looking a pilot up
and forward freeway from the baikonur
okay why I'm against what it is a whole
hog pushing a freaking blue back again
they want to take this payload out right
here right now and a very low Knights
right click propose another one at time
ooh the hero on this row dog roll Valley
and low will hold - mines are carpet how
does this dupe now he's like there
there's something oh my gosh
I mean find the Kelvin Gamzee in midair
twice my boom oh my insane moving
get all go hi I'm thinking on that
Widowmaker in party politicans
whoa hi boo Pierre now reaches about it
Widowmaker no I told oh do that timer
knew where he was because it will affect
that McMahon to me and for that far as
you punch jumping down Kevin get the
shield very finely calm they're going to
get struggling Amos you get the self you
have a flick supplies on voice you can't
one of the support is like when it goes
down timing for black ones please not me
down with keep getting their selfish
also offense get up the bottom line in
the hands down let's women of all strong
in they will take them out on Kings Road
right now comes in nano boost on the
time who should we get something to get
the kill their death losses in the back
that's a good angle for envious to come
in here time you get three my boo get
for now and that's going to be an easy
point a Corinthian page that's going to
be no fun
overall from behind time coming in with
a flag on the road Hagen man he has been
the MVP of his defense Reza has another
wild man he finally goes down to just
hook after hook right click after
rifling hatred been patient rather
making throws yells industry like
anybody with it there's a graviton surge
from Rogen applause the time of Dragon
everybody on that Reaper finally get the
kill on the AKM he has an attaboy as
well and n beautiful just roll through
point B that's the rift if you run
though I hear you make those kind of
huge switches your competition that's
why but Finland not being merciful today
is going to force of a way to hook comes
in Ankara he gets shots as well okay
it's going to back away third the
eliminations for firing 8,000 damage
done math it's birthday girl thirty
thirty to one is that right oh my word
it is not able to find his target hairy
hook now get focused and he will get off
down time ooh strike and further he's
got the point that slices his way
through wait a minute just one little
chances pirate rock mentality can't keep
a low face the rest of Russia try keep
the pinned on the side shadow Berg
continues the strike it again no IDs
dessa and our fourth away for the points
just add the vodka
1hp is what parties had remaining after
that one is old places like these might
get on the pointed campus 24 both sides
of timer right now coming in at the
alums our get to get the triple kill
going to get the quad by boom pulling it
right back bite for consumption tonight
and then we're going to open here that
I'm looking for those happy little
skulls all charged up as deadly does
take your Chi Chi Minh get to kill on
the Devon
oh my goodness hi folks two people with
one flash bag coming down right now
the toe force claim is that down but MD
is one of a full six on the point here I
don't know if this can be enough but my
t9 is high tides it's a bunch of the
base I'm on a quad kill once more an
timers had a great last five minutes of
between this game and laughing thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button